[Music]
our team is the elite of the elite
we're the heart soul of this very Beach
we protect when other people don't want
to protect and we go above and beyond
[Music]
if you want me you can have me some
other time
we're staring into the abyss here City
Council's already cut our funding it's
up to us to restore the Baywatch brand
I'm Matt Brodie ready for duty you just
look at my boobs I usually look at my
face I'm trying but it's so close to
your boobs yeah this is the guy you
think it's a good PR opportunity for you
some shots he's reckless
with two gold medals I mean gold medals
do you have probably zero we got a dead
body on our Beach that's not our job my
gut says there's a bad [ __ ] going on
over there that my balls say we need to
check it out i ball say he's just
thinking he's right what your ball sound
like three-year-old girls
I don't know man that's just how they
talk but they're wise welcome to
Baywatch are you surprised
why does she always like she's running
in slow-mo you see it too
you turn the canals into the dam x-games
yeah
that's cuz we were in lifeguard pursuits
there's no such thing as lifeguard
pursuit how do I explain this so that
you people understand you people you
people oh you don't get to say that
you're just ten right oh come on brother